hello everyone and welcome to
this talk my name is seva shri and today
i will present the paper
lower bounds for off chain protocols
exploring the limits of plasma
this is a joint worked with stefan
jimbovsky gregor fabianski sebastian
faust and missionary
are from university of western poland
and sebastian and i are from tio
darmstadt
in germany let's start with some
motivation
we as humans need to maintain ledgers or
logbooks
for many different applications such as
for trading legal agreements or banking
traditionally trusted entities such as
the stock market notaries or banks
maintain these ledgers
but recent events in the past few
decades have shown that
these trusted entities are not really
trustworthy for example there's a
scandal regarding a company called
wirecard in the germany stock market or
we all remember the 2008 housing crisis
which affected the global
market and the global finance situation
quite substantially
therefore people have been thinking how
can we force these entities to actually
behave honestly as they're supposed to
well one can try to achieve this by
using transparencies
or forcing these entities to be more
transparent
in order to detect misbehaviors early on
but others have been focusing on getting
rid of these trusted entities all
together
one of the proposals to do so is using
blockchains
and i must point out that there is quite
a huge realistic and sometimes
unrealistic hype
around blockchain and blockchain
technologies
and our work also tries to
bring the real the expectations from
protocols run over the blockchain
to a more realistic level
but what is blockchain well blockchain's
core
is a consensus algorithm where we have a
set of parties and as long as more than
half of the parties are honest
they can agree on the latest state of
the system and reach consensus
but lower scale consensus is actually
expensive
and that's one of the reasons why
blockchain was not able to really
replace
the trusted entities which i mentioned
in the previous slides
for example bitcoin can process
10 transactions per second while visa
payment system can process up to 50 000
transactions per second
this this gap really shows that
blockchain technology doesn't really
scale in this case
there have been many uh proposals
in order to improve blockchain
scalability one of the more recent ones
and the focus of this works work is
off-chain protocols
and by off-chain i mean that parties
only communicate with the blockchain
if it is necessary and they try to keep
their communication with the blockchain
to a minimum
let me at this point give a summary
of our contribution in this paper
i would like to point out that many of
the terms that i will use in this slide
i have not defined yet but i will define
them in the rest of this talk
we analyze a class of off-chain
protocols called plasma protocols
which was introduced by punimbuturin in
2017.
more specifically we show that there is
no perfect plasma protocol
in other words either a plasma protocol
has large exit sizes
which means that they have to
communicate a lot with a blockchain
or they suffer from a phenomenon called
non-uniquely attributable
mass exits and there does not exist
a perfect plasma where both the exercise
is small and
there are no non-uniquely attributable
mass exits
as i said earlier i will define all the
undefined terms in this slide
later in this talk here is the content
and overview of this
of the talk i i by now gave an
introduction and motivation
i will continue with some background on
blockchain then i will define what
platform protocols are
and finally i will summarize our results
first let me try to give you a basic
introduction about blockchain which
you can also usually see in the
materials available online or that is
usually the way that blockchains are
motivated blockchains can be seen
and modeled as a trusted party who can
do the following
one maintain a ledger this means that
the
the blockchain is maintaining the latest
balances of the users
involved in the blockchain second it can
process transactions so parties can send
coins to one another and finally the
blockchain can even write grant code
which are referred to as smart contracts
these codes can also have balances
and the the the the smart contracts can
distribute
their balances according to the rules in
their
court i would like to point out that
not all blockchains support smart
contracts
but many of the recent blockchains such
as ethereum indeed support
execution of code called smart contracts
over them furthermore
it is expensive to communicate with this
trusted party
because this trusted party is modeling
the blockchain that has to run the
consensus algorithm
or you can think of this trusted party
as a judge which needs to decide
whether someone gets some amount of coin
or not so
we would like to keep the communication
with this blockchain over this
structured entity to a minimum
now that i've given you a basic overview
about blockchain i want to give you a
different perspective about blockchain
blockchains can be seen as public
timestamping logs
where one can prove
that the message m was publicly
available at time t
this is quite useful because then a
party can actually prove
that for example a patent was publicly
available to everyone or a paper was
probably available to everyone
how would this look like well let's say
we have a party who has a message
he pulls this message by a transaction
to the blockchain
and after it is accepted by the
blockchain network
it is timestamped and everyone can
actually see this message
over the blockchain but
this message can be potentially long and
as we discussed before publishing
long message might be expensive due to
the scalability issues of the blockchain
so in order to tackle this we can try to
weaken the guarantees that we expect
from
the time stamping so we define a weak
time stamping
guarantee where a party proves that he
knew a message
at time t but this message m might not
have been publicly available so for
example i can
later prove that i know who would have
become the latest president of the
united states
but i did not really post this guess
over the blockchain
well how would this look like instead of
posting the message m directly to the
blockchain
this party first hashes this message
using a cryptographically secure hash
function
and then pulls this hash over the
blockchain and after it is accepted by
the system
by the blockchain it is timestamped to
sum up
we have two variants of timestamping
strong version which has better
guarantees
but is more expensive and the weaker
version which is weaker connected but is
less expensive
but even this weaker version might be
too expensive it's large number of users
we should timestamp at the same time
so how can we deal with this well we can
introduce something or design a protocol
called timestamping as a service
assume we have five parties with five
different messages and one to m5
and an operator instead of parties
separately timestamping their messages
they send their messages first to the
operator the operator concatenates all
these messages to a large message m
and then timestamps the hash of this m
to the blockchain and further returns m
to the users
this is necessary such that parties can
actually verify that their
mi was indeed included in them because
this is not clear from the hash of the
message m
this idea can be further optimized using
mercury but due to time concerns
i will not go into the details of
how it can be optimized using my
countries what i just described
is an example of an offchain protocol
because parties try to minimize their
interaction with the blockchain
and only interact with the blockchain if
necessary
now you might already see that there is
a problem
with what i just described what if
the operator is malicious and does not
explain
this hfm or does not return m to the
users
well in this case the users need to
times up their messages themselves
separately
because they are not sure if their
message was timestamped or not
this type of attack is called data and
availability
where the operators simply withhold some
data from the users
the biggest problem with data and
availability is that it is non-uniquely
attributable
what do i mean by that a c of alice
goes through george and says the
operator mounted the data in
availability attack
i did not receive them from him
the church cannot be certain if alice is
telling the truth or not because it
could very well be that the operator
was honest but alice is lying and she
indeed received m from the operator
in other words no judge can decide who
is malicious the accuser or the accused
this would be quite problematic for
plasma protocols and i will
discuss discusses later in the talk
okay now that we have seen this time
stamping as a service
let us try to extend this concept and
build an off chain bank
and this option bank is indeed what we
refer to as plasma
note that in the literature plaza
protocols are also called commit chain
so the main idea behind plasma protocols
is as follows
instead of parties submitting their
transaction to the blockchain
they submit their transactions to the
operator which must be digitally signed
of course
furthermore the operator periodically
timestamps the latest state of the
system
plasma system such that the parties can
refer to their balance which they had
in the plasma plasma system
more precisely the operator maintains
his own ledger l
he publishes the content of l off chain
for example on his own web page
and he periodically for example once per
hour
publishes the hash of l over the
blockchain
let me continue with an example and this
would be the running example that we'll
use for the rest of this talk
we have three parties alice bob and
charlie and the i state of the plasma
system is as follows alice has five
coins bob has
uh three coins and charlie has seven
coins now parties can make transactions
alice can say i want to send one coin to
bob bob can say he wants to send three
coins to charlie
the operator gathers these transactions
and updates the state of the
plasma latch furthermore as i mentioned
before
the operator needs to timestamp
periodically the state
of the plasma ledger technically
these hash values are indeed stored on
the plasma
smart contract such that the parties can
later refer to them right
what i just described can be extended to
allow depositing and withdrawing assets
directly from the blockchain to the
smart plasma smart contract
using the monetary capabilities of the
blockchain let me try to give an
uh give a high level overview
assume li is the latest state of the
plasma system
which means that the plasma smart
contract has a balance of 15 coins
because the sum
of all the balance of the users here is
15.
alice submits a transaction
which states that she sends one coin to
the smart contract
this increases the balance of the smart
contract to sixteen
and of course reduces the balance of
alice on chain by one
in the next state of the uh plasma
ledger alice's balance would be
increased by one to six
in order to incorporate the transaction
that you just made
i left a lot of details out here due to
time reasons but if you want a more
detailed explanation i would refer you
to our paper or the materials that are
available online regarding plasma
protocols
furthermore i will not explain how
exiting works the process is
very similar to deposit
here i would like to point out that one
of the features of plasma protocols is
that the operator
does not need to have collateral in the
system
so the operator does not have to
additionally put money in the system
in order to guarantee security this is
in contrast to other off-chain
protocols such as channels where the
operator or the intermediary
indeed needs to put huge amount of
collaterals in order to
guarantee security we will not go into
details how channels work here i would
just like to
point out this for for for people who
are familiar
uh with with channels and plasma
protocols
so what are the main features of plasma
protocols well
we expect that if the operator is honest
you will achieve huge
unchanged savings and that is indeed
true because the parties do not have to
submit their transactions
on check they submitted often this is
quite good
but we also expect that the malicious
operator cannot really steal coins
to achieve this parties need to solve
conflicts unchecked for example if some
data and availability attack happens
parties need to solve this answer which
means that users have to monitor both
the blockchain and often instead of the
system to see if they match and
everything checks out
there are quite a lot of variants of
plasma protocols that have been designed
this is a picture from 2018
and some of the projects here might be
abandoned already
but as you can see people have really
tried to produce specific plasma
protocols for specific purposes
but all in all we can categorize plasma
into two main categories
one plasma cache where users own tokens
similar to
cache and two fungible plasma
also known as plasma mvp or norcaster
users have accounts
similar to checking accounts and
as in real life implementing plasma cash
is easier than implementing fungible
plasma
well we have had cash for like thousands
of years but checking accounts have been
around for maybe
uh a few centuries at most
and we'll see later why this is also the
case here in these two variants of
plasma
in a bit more details in plasma cache we
assign
tokens to users for example token one
here belongs to user two
token two belong to user one and a user
can actually own multiple tokens
a fundamental plasma however is kind of
the other way around
users are assigned to the number of
tokens they own
so uh and this number can also be a real
number it doesn't have to be like
a natural number similar real world
cache
if if a user wants to withdraw k tokens
from the plasma cache system he needs to
withdraw them individually
so he needs to actually communicate a
lot
with a blockchain this is also the same
situation with cash if i go to a bank
and
if i want we want to withdraw a lot of
money in pay-perform
well i might just need to bring a
suitcase with me
however fungible plasma similar to real
checks is more prone to cheating
and that is what we'll explain in the
next slide
fungible plasma suffers from a
phenomenon referred to as mass exits
let's see this in an example assume li
is the latest state of the plasma system
but the operator turns malicious and
does not really explain
the new state li 1 to the users
now you might be wondering okay why is
this a problem
well what if a malicious user who is
colluding with the operator now
has a balance of 15. so the balance of
this user is increased to 50.
well this user can actually drain the
smart contract
he can if this user actually exits with
15 coins
there won't be enough coins available
for the rest of the users
to exit which means honest users must
exit before it is too late
this is called mass exits because
parties have to exit
immediately
recall that this attack this this mass
exit phenomenon is called by data and
availability
which is non-uniquely attributable
now why doesn't plasma cache suffer from
mass exits
well plasma cache offers something
called exit challenges
assume here that we have three tokens
assigned to alice bob and charlie
and the operator turns malicious and
says no no token 3 actually belongs to
me or another party that i know
no longer belongs to charlie
and he withholds this latest state of
the system
so we're again on the date and
availability attack
now if at some point this malicious user
tries to exit token3
charlie will get mad but charlie can do
something smart here he can say
well i own token 3 and li in
state i the id state of the ledger the
plasma ledger
so you're claiming that token 3 now
belongs to you
give me a proof that i transferred
token3
since the transaction must be signed and
forging
charlie's digital signature would be
impossible except with some negligible
probability
the adversary would fail here and can
indeed be punished
for for trying to steal charlie's coin
to sum up plasma cash translating plasma
cash transferring coins require digital
signature
which means that the malicious operator
cannot really steal coins
and hemisphere behavior can easily be
challenged over the blockchain
but fungible plasma is not like plasma
cache operator connected to increase
another user's balance
he can stop explaining the latest state
of the system to the users and users
cannot easily detect what went wrong and
they cannot easily challenge it
which brings us to the table that i
showed at the beginning of the talk
plasma cache suffers from large exit
sizes but does not suffer from
non-uniquely attributable mass exits
but fungible plasma although having
short exit sizes
suffers from non-nuclear attributable
mass exits
now you might be wondering are messages
a huge problem
well they indeed are because blockchains
have low throughput and cannot really
handle some intense in many exits
therefore exit timeouts must be large i
think in the plasma community they
usually refer to seven days which is
quite a lot compared to other systems
such as visa or normal banking systems
furthermore the attack that i just
described doesn't have any cost for the
operator
the operator must simply withhold data
and
the attack is not uniquely attributable
which means no one can be really
punished for it
now the main question is is this
separation inherent
in other words is there a plasma
protocol with short exercises and no
mass exits
well this brings us to our result we
answer this question
in our work and the answer is
no there is no perfect plasma protocol
i would refer you to our paper for the
full proof
and the detailed results but in short
we show that either we have a situation
like plasma cache
which requires large exits or we have a
situation like fungible plasma
which requires mass exits let me give
the main idea
behind this proof and the observation
that we had
assume now we have three parties where
alice has one coin bob has zero coins
and charlie has one
coin now alice
which means that actually the the total
balance of the
plasma contract is two now alice
sends one coin to bob which means that
the next state of the system would have
bob
with one coin furthermore the operator
doesn't publish this state to the honest
users which is charlie here
pop tries to honestly exit from the
system and he should be
able to do this everything went through
honestly
and he can exit one coin which means the
balance
of the system would be reduced by one
now alice can try to revert her state
towards stating an i and claim that she
never transferred any coins to bob
an attempt to exit naturally if alice
exits
charlie will not be able to exit so how
can we
prevent alice from exiting here well
either
it is clear from bob's exit that alice
cannot exit which means that we are in
some situation like plasma cache
where bob is exiting a token and a token
cannot be
exited twice or charlie must exit before
alice which would be which would mean
that you will end up in a situation
like plasma like fungible plasma
now let me try to extend this idea and
give more intuition behind our proof
until now we had only three parties but
what if instead of just three parties
we have two n plus one parties
we have n parties here
which we refer to as camp alice and n
party
which we refer to as camp charlie and
the alice
camp is chosen randomly by the operator
and corrupted
and the parties in camp charlie are
separated from the rest of the system so
they're under data and availability
attack
furthermore the total balance in the
system is 2n
instead of just two coins
now the parties in camp alice can send
all their coins
to bob bob can as before
try to exit all his new coins which
would mean
that the new state of the system would
only include
end coins
parties in camp alice can also claim now
that they never sent any coins to bob
now in order to guarantee security no
one
from camp alice should be allowed to
exit therefore the description of camp
alice
should actually be known to the smart
contract otherwise if even one person
from campbell's exits
there is one person from camp charlie
that is not able to exit anymore
hence the total communication with the
contract must be overall large why
because cap alice was chosen randomly
and a random subset cannot
be compressed more than some certain
amount
and and therefore in order to describe
this set to the smart contract
the overall communication must be large
which means that either bob's exit was
large or
people in camp charlie try to mass exit
note that for technical reasons we
assume communication locality which
means that users only communicate with
the operator
this is necessary and are not with each
other this is necessary in order to
exclude trivial
protocols where parties actually run
some consensus algorithm of chain
which is not the goal of plasma the goal
of plasma is to actually
scale the blockchain and running a
consensus algorithm of chain between
a huge number of users is not really
scalable
with this i would like to conclude this
talk
we initiate the study of lower bounds
for off-chain protocols
and we show that there is an inherent
separation between plasma cache
and fungible plasma which means that
both plasma variants have
their place and use cases for example if
the operator is semi-trusted
then fungible plasma would be much more
efficient than plasma cache
but in case the operator becomes
malicious
then plasma cache might be a better
choice
now regarding future works well we just
initiated the study of lower bounds for
off-chain protocol so there are
many things that can be worked upon and
improved
for example we only analyzed plasma
protocols but there are
huge class of other off-chain protocols
such as channels channel networks or
virtual channels
which can be analyzed furthermore
one can improve our results by by seeing
whether
for example this assumption regarding
communication locality can be changed or
removed
or try to change some of the modeling
choices that we made and see if
if the the same result can be achieved
with this i would like to
thank you all for your attention and if
you have any questions
feel free to contact me any of the
co-authors
or use the live panel to ask your
questions thank you very much